[Music]
thank you so we might be closing the
doors there maybe thank you so hello
everyone my name is Yun Smith I'm
working for wrote the Rosen group and
I'm giving a talk about the very
beginning of our downtown sign
success stories that you probably all
have in the in the projects we see that
in a moment
um I'll be due to be technical problems
that we had the very beginning for force
to really rush through the presentation
and which I was expecting it a bit so
I've prepared good for that we see that
so as I said Gentiles my name I mean my
background is extend experimental
physics when I started physics I also
got into Python it is more than twenty
years ago I started with Python with r1
before the first dots and it immediately
catched me I was driving all the
exponent with that and introduced that
at the prototyping language for the
company that I work for I work for Rosen
I work at the technology and research
center which is really the backbone for
all the non technology that we use
throughout the world and you can find me
on Twitter you can finally and get up um
for those of you who would like to
really follow that talk there's no need
to download it it's available on my
github repository you can recap it
afterwards and simply lean back and
enjoy
that's good that's nice thank you um so
as I said a usual data science workflow
success looks like this you have data
you will be applying fancy algorithms
and you've got all some results
the usual talk is focusing on the latter
one
I won't we will be talking about the
usual suspects at the very beginning
which is often overlooked and
underestimated to get you so the story
behind this as I said I work for loading
and we are renown full of doing pipeline
inspection services which is at first
glance not really data related but we
are the ones building devices traveling
through the pipeline these pigs pigs and
pipe for pipeline inspection gauge these
are traveling along the pipeline
collecting data by measuring the
complete sequence alien's of the
pipeline we're running for more than a
thousand kilometres such a device might
roll up to two weeks autonomously doing
all the measurements and we collecting
multiple terabytes is downtown
we have customers throughout the world
do multiple inspections at a time so we
have a really large data set available
which brings us into the area of big
data as well so when you're about to do
new data centric services which is the
outcome of you're collecting the data
and providing the reports to our
customers and you need to aggregate your
storage solutions which we did all the
time we've started as probably most
companies and very beginning to have the
data below your desk and each and every
project has its own data you have the
teams working on the data they know what
they are working about hardly anyone
knows what the other team has so the
first way to getting more professional
is you're using real servers for that
which scale in a way but still people
need to know where the data is that they
will be using and today we've aggregated
to a single file system on an EMC Isilon
storage which is currently about 1.5
petabytes of data
and that is a good thing if you want to
aggregate but it does not solve all your
problems so the beginning levels by this
solution quite some satisfaction as you
get really high performance by that sort
of setup as really vast performs you
could do more than two or three
gigabytes of reads and writes a second
but over the years new services started
to be developed and the directory
structures changed and the data farmers
are being optimized new file formats get
introduced people under pressure I get
creative and storing their data away to
get the project has a deadline and those
copies of copies of data around it
started to diverge again which get us
get us a terrible headache so that's a
mess that we just may call dark data
which according to Gartner which they
know what they are doing is understood
to be the information assets that
organizing organizations collects
process and store doing regular business
activities but generally fail to use for
other purposes and that's exactly what
we faced we had all the projects all the
teams working on their data and hardly
anyone knew what the other team was was
working on so there was no single person
at a company in knowing what data is
really available so to get the over view
image of what data is available that we
had we had a hard time of that and it's
just too expensive to state at this
point such in such an ideal on-base
storage is really good storage but it's
costly so our IT department they wanted
to really know what data is stored on
the ideal and why is it stored on the
eyes and that other disk such is such an
expensive solution
I am doing and enjoying my best so are
lessons learned reveal that
restructuring is a data is not a good
idea we did this when we moved on
because our storage solutions it was
always the idea when to get to the next
so let's start with a new structure new
directory structure make it better but
then people get more creative and it
starts to emerge again and usually there
was a good reason for this divergence
and in the Dante metal that you just
need to face so the better idea we
thought was to offer smart services to
finding and retrieving the data that
should significantly reduce the cost at
the initial stages and this is actually
what this talk is about
so we've planned a variety of
interacting services such as a
filesystem scanner which will keep track
of all the files that are stored on the
I salon and that will generate and its
results a smart table of contents and we
thought about a tagging service for
these files that you can label it as
just as you would do with your photo
collection at home and the data provider
that will serve all the data about REST
API for example and that will help to
get a first look into the data and tags
and we will focus today on the first
component of this which is a distributed
file system scanner so now we are
already getting to the part 2 which is
about all the implementations that is
probably what you were expecting to see
today and keeping up with the tradition
and being very native you will probably
start in just looking what files are
there with the traditional find command
and that will probably just generate a
file system a list of files which you
can redirect to the file and we use that
command finds less tenth I bet that will
just generate all the generate a list of
files in your temp file system and we
could we implement this using Python and
following the official Python
documentation you end up in something
like this by importing from us and
important time to do some benchmark if
you like with a given entry dear and
providing an empty list of files you can
use always walk with an entry directory
which will generate on its way all
desires and the directories it finds in
the entry dia together with its path as
soon as you go and append these items to
emptiness you will get something very
similar that's just a list of files and
it's costly to generate if you remember
that you're going to list a 1.5
petabytes system and that skin already
takes 12 hours to complete so there's
not something that you're really up to
in your day to day work if you're
searching for files using that
technology and it's not even having any
detail so we might be interested in
other things like care the base
directory of that file that you can for
later analysis do some grouping about
this the file name itself the type of
the file to also look how many data sets
for its specific type you have how many
images
how many Word documents something like
that the size of the file the ownership
so who is owning the data would be might
be responsible for the data and several
times lens for your bookkeeping there
you can see how often are other files
accessed and how old it is and we came
up with a last seen times 10 which is
quite a night a nice idea I think if you
repeat this file system scan then you
might find your files again and then you
know that there's still available on
your file system if you're no longer
finding these the diet together at the
time stamp is not getting updated so if
you're searching on the result list then
you at least know that some file existed
at some time ago and you can search for
it in the archives maybe otherwise if
the last thing times gain is current
then you know you can access it so with
these additional properties they can be
retrieved by a NOAA stat call which is
also a bit more expensive
but we're doing this you can also just
narrow down your list when you do the
always walk you will just get any item
in the directory also symbolic links
heartening device entries and stuff like
that which might not be useful for what
we are about so this is something that
we could wipe out at the very beginning
so we're writing a little help law for
that get file info just gets apart and
by splitting up that in the directory in
the file name and splitting up the file
types by this good xed you can get the
very first and most important
informations and then you do your stat
core and get the size and the owner and
the group and these timestamps and that
is the basic concept that will it will
see throughout these this talk that will
be the basic functionality that is
called an old all the items that you
defined so if you write rewrite this and
use that get file in for methods that
skill changes to this we're still using
it always walk for it and I'm going over
the directories now over all the files
that you would find in each and every
iteration then you can look in to a
video file or as a symbolic link if
that's the case and just continue
because that's not of interest and if
not then get the information and
appended to our list of files let's can
take 16 hours as we have more
information at Anzio stetko is quite
expensive so that's still nothing to
work with in their day to day base but
having this it's quite neat to put it in
a data frame and just for having the
table and as you might know you can do
some proper statistics on it already
just counting and grouping and finding
the largest files of stuff that like
that that could be interesting in the
future
with these result organized like so and
you might find insights from the numbers
such as the number of files that you
have and five count how many files are
there who's the owner of this your wall
size the file types and more and how to
generate this detail you might be bonus
features we have enough time at the very
end to see how that works
it will also be using the same
technology but it's also interesting to
keep track how long the directory scan
is actually taking if we have
benchmarked it and in more detail then
you would see maybe such a graph which
just shows you the number of files and
other file entries or entries in the
directory and the scanning time that it
took just for the beginning of this and
then you can see that you in the very
beginning it's it's quite quick there's
just few files in the sub directory and
it's the deeper you go the more files
are there and the directory and the sad
thing is that the file systems are very
capable of storing as many files and
directories as you want but making a
list of it may take a lot of time so
this is the base that was the real
problem that when you're facing that you
can't see all the numbers here because
it's from the very beginning but we have
directories on our eyes alone which have
more than 60,000 entries in it there was
sort of an idea to debug an algorithm
was it search run for anomalies in the
data set and that guy has gotten very
creative by making an image of each
enemy anomaly that he found and stored
it in a file in the same directory
ending up in more than 60,000 files in
this and that can takes more than eight
minutes just for that simple directory
so if you have some more of that that
will really take some time and that's
the thing to address now
so most of the directory can be quickly
scanned as soon as you have a large
number of entries that will
significantly slow down the us walk
based approach is the most traditional
way of doing this but luckily there is a
version that is more efficient than this
introduced in Python 3 which is called
OS candia that is working on iterators
and it will do will return
dear entry objects and they have the
start calls included this will probably
give us a small speed up on this so
that's the change get silence or
function it looks quite similar and it
is is now no longer working on the path
but on that directory entry object and
therefore just usually uses its start
information to return the same
information that before and we will be
using another neat concept to loop over
the files now based on scan D because
scan D is just a function for one
directory is no longer that always walk
thing you have to re-implement the idea
of iterating of the complete subtree and
that's how we end up doing this we will
be creating an initial to-do list and
that to-do list is filled with all the
entries at the top-level directory and
we will be trying to with each and every
iteration empty that to-do list and
reset it with new directories that we
find so when we find simple files then
we will just be appending those to our
list of files and all directories will
be appended to the to do list while we
go so in this in this main block for
entry into do we are just really
scanning each nether directory trying to
remove entries from our to-do list and
refilling it until we're completing the
complete subdirectory scan
and this gives us another speed up again
so we're down from 16 hours to 14 again
we save two hours when what we're not
anywhere near of using this on QuickBase
air in your daily work and that is just
because of the blocking behavior that we
see when we have the directory with many
entries in it and we are working on a
single CPU so can we go multi-core down
of course yes we could scale a bit and
the idea is to distinguish between
directory and file entries and handle
them separately and to do the next scan
even before we have completed the
current one which is taking a long time
that's the idea of going parallel ending
multiple CPUs at work so we still should
have a single to do your circulatory but
a number of workers completing the job
and the most straightforward approach
for this is using a mapping concept
behind it so you have a list of
directories that we should scan and have
some workers and have a system which
will be applying that scanning function
onto that list of parameters that's the
basic mapping a process can use a title
so let's create a function that we can
use on the mapping process which mimics
they always walk and that is the scanned
here which takes a route directory which
will create a list of directories and
files and as soon as we're iterating
over the scan the results and that
directory is that entry is a directory
we will be appending it to our directory
list eligible and pending off our list
and just return it with its
corresponding path so we have the same
calling API that we had with the ORS
walk
and now the idea is to have a pool of
workers that is mapping the
functionality the mapping our Scandia
function onto our to-do lists reducing
it on the fly
and that's what it looks like and it
will be using multi processing for that
for example which creates processes with
that multi processing pool I've chosen
two CPUs for this the machine that I use
it has two cores and then I'm in an
endless loop that while true loop trying
to empty my to-do list as soon as that's
happening I'm really exiting all my
through my wire true block and I'm
finished my work else I will do the
mapping to that tool with that scan Li a
function on my non empty to-do list and
it will extend my to-do list with all
the results and then we're repeating
this until we finished our to-do list to
be empty this is what it looks like a
couple of columns the first one is the
one with the iteration the second one is
the length of our to-do list so you can
see that is really I'm filling up until
a certain point and then it's trying to
empty it again and that's got a notable
speed up are we are seven hours again
which is half the timeline before which
is good scales nicely by a factor of two
from 14 to 7 9 minutes the seven hours
but it's still nothing really good in
offer to doing office hours so what we
really should do is scaling up using not
only multiple calls but more people
computers to complete the work and that
is something to keep up with the time
you can do with a modern environment
that it's the one that is representing
my vironment most of the Linux boxes so
those of you who are working windows
might be on the south side now it's not
as sure that is really working on
Windows and everything else could be
done on a Linux machine and also AM a
class with using in a proper
kondou environment so what we'll be
using fall is to go the scale out is
dark and does distribute it which is a
from the docks a lightweight library for
distributed computing in Python it
extends the conquering futures and dusk
api's to moderate sized clusters which
you can simply install using condense
told us distributed from the Condor
forge channel and then you're ready to
go and task itself it has been created
to address large memory intense problems
but it was meant to be a simple solution
to problems where data to we worked on
no longer fits into memory which in the
old days before does you had to split up
that data manually and find your way how
it iterally directly solve your problem
and work with intermediate results to
your final result sets and or maybe we
enter the world of distributed computing
using MPI for example which can be
tricky and hard is also a bit like for
this sort of problem using a
sledgehammer to crack your nuts
Darth with the dart you could use to
locally to extend your local storage
with with an SSD for example that was
the basic idea and to be a drop-in
replacement for nuclear ace implementing
the same API so as soon as you had an
oompa matrix for example no longer
fitting into memory you would have to
split up a manual asset as I just said
before and with the idea of - you will
be using best
duska api and death will do all the
sense of stuff below the hood for you so
you can must not change your guerrillas
than anyway - to be able to use that
what it does under the hood is creating
a task graph which is iterated it's a
bit like if you're having to sum up some
numbers and multiplying numbers then you
end up in doing a graph with that
numbers and say 2 plus 2 in terms of the
graph it's plus operational with this
two numbers and two and two makes for
that gate also a task graph which you
can iterate on and dark is doing pretty
much the same thing of all the
operations that you would do on your
numpy array to make the work complete if
it's no longer fitting into memory and
once they introduce some level
communication code they will be able to
only use the local CPUs and your
multi-core but also you use multiple
computers to perform the work laws
knives and that is what is been
implemented by the distributed part of
tasks and that is exactly what we will
be using now so the idea is to have a
central scheduler keeping track of all
the work and have a number of workers
which will performing all the work and
if you starting in exploring how task
words it's very advisable to start off
with a local cluster and as you don't
have to set up your network for this and
it will behave exactly like the final
solution so let's leave that leave that
for the ideas of instead of creating
water emoji processing pool we will
create a local cluster with the same
number of processes and connect the
network scheduler to it and it's still
the idea of emptying the dynamic to-do
list
and which now will help future objects
which is a concept abused by the
asynchronous programming idea into
Python these features will directly
return and the corresponding resolves
and they can be expected to come at some
point in time once the job is complete
so they can be awaited
and I've distributed you can use the as
completed function to iterate over the
results this helps to loop over all the
results as they come in instead of the
order they have been filled in and so
using local cluster back-end should be
quite comparable to what we known from
the multi processing pool and I'm sure
you can recognize this so we are
creating a local cluster there at the
very top with the same number of workers
that we have another motion processing
pool and we will be creating a client
which is connecting to that cluster
that's the basic system that's the basic
thing that we is implementing the same
thing as a multi processing pool and we
are also preparing our to-do list and
which is now called futures that list
and submit our jobs to that to the
client with that client to the workers
initially and then we are iterating in
that wild block over the futures list
and take each and every future out of it
as it is completed we tweeze the results
and extend our list of files and
directories again
and if you look at it it will pretty
much look the same as we have before it
will take 8 hours instead of 7 which is
the drawback at the very beginning that
is a slight overhead in it with a
scheduler and the workers doing jobs but
there will be changing in a minute by
getting to the real distributed cluster
and this one you can build by absolutely
little helper utility which is provided
by ask distributed as well which is the
dark secure shell
helper where you can start on a number
of workers in this case on ten machines
with 16 processes and one threat by this
I just decide is real process instead of
a threading approach you can exchange it
and we'll see just one process and
halibut in 1/16 rats for example
something you should decide based on
your problem that you want to solve if
you want to work it then you should make
sure that all the nodes have the same
file system mounted in and there is an
anaconda environment installed at the
very same location because the idea
behind our distributed is to take the
source code deliver it over the network
by the scheduler to the workers and
serialize it and execute it so if you're
depending on external libraries they
should be somewhere in place and then we
look at the change that we need to do it
well is simple one you're no longer
doing the local cluster thing as we had
done it externally using dart secure
shell and connect our client to the node
at the proper port and the rest is just
the same so that's just the idea of
going from a local host with multi CPU
to distribute cluster and if you see at
the results the first rows are pretty
much the same but we've completed that
job in less than R and that is really a
vast speed-up that we've been waiting
for and if you look at the numbers
correctly the two middle columns is the
number of directories that I have been
found in our directory scan on the eyes
alone which is half a million
directories and these half a million
directories have more than 60 million
files in it so that's a large number and
it's better be organized and there's
something other need to see as soon as
you go to the distributed cluster or
something which I could stare on or a
but is this an excerpt of the Status
page that the task scheduler provides
so this is up and running then you can
travel to a lot webpage offered by the
scheduler based on bouquet and it will
show you the status on going in time
here each and every row every bar and
the top is a single job that is done by
one of the 160 workers and the progress
bar at the bottom is shown the
advancement in your complete job in this
case emptying that to do next so my
message to take home we're near the end
already by rushing through it if you
could scale up from the very beginning
as it is simple it's as soon as you are
familiar with the concept of mapping
functionality to list of parameters it's
in quite an easy way you're starting off
with multi processing pool as soon as
that successful you're switching over to
das distributable the local cluster and
that is going okay then you're setting
up your network with a distributed
cluster with as many calls as you like
and you shouldn't force creating
instructions prior collecting your data
it takes a lot of time and effort to try
to get structure into it for us the
better idea was to offer this smart
table of contents so the result of this
is that we by doing the scan created a
list of CSV files and these CSV files
get uploaded to a MongoDB database and
on top of this is another service which
is providing the data but it's fine so
you can explore it quickly and we run it
every night so we're quite up to date
with the contents you should publish the
table of contents as as often as you
could you should document the data which
is really overlooked one that if you're
working with a data you're absolutely
familiar with it but the next team might
having a hard time in understanding what
the data that you use really means you
should create awareness of what's there
and what's the value behind this is so
within your project you usually just use
the data and once it is complete what
are you doing with the data are you
interested in the data after your work
is complete most usually no because work
is done
next thing to come but as the data is
stored on the file system on an iPhone
for example it's pretty expensive so you
should put some value to it and value to
it is something like tagging it making
it useful for others and keeping track
of what's behind the data so we already
through if there any questions I would
be happy to answer it thank you more
distributed content that's right yeah so
so the either longing is already a
distributed solution for itself which is
which is able to scale off to be pretty
easily yeah so that's the idea to do
have a smart usage of listing in the
father that still on demand say the gun
thing is killing us
the file system how to scale it is the
question yeah you will buy new note and
attach it to them and it will rebalance
everything that is stored on it and
provide you with some new network mix to
scale of the bandwidth as well
yes it is here it's here
if there are no more questions do that
then we get the bonus round it's just a
quick one
and it's the idea how I'm I'm scanning
and the results and get some insights
onto it and there is the idea as I said
all the results get stored in CSV files
and as soon as that's the case when you
have many cs35 csv files for each and
every working so in this case 160 you
can use the pandas distributed data
flame to access that and accelerate and
your analysis of insights and let me
idea how to do it you use resi as being
on the csv files and explain your data
and help it to understand the data and
then you can define tasks that should be
completed on this pandas dataframe let's
again the idea of creating tasks which
will be iterated on to complete in this
case was just getting idea of the number
of files with are there the sizable
files the number of ACH
five five files that's a special for
that we use the size of it a number of
project related science and the size of
project related fires and some more
specific stuff to do none the directory
name the extension of the UID and the
project and then you use the compute
method to complete all the tasks that's
where the fun starts which looks like
this that's again our progress bar now
you can see the workers completing all
the related works by iterating over the
subtasks that need to be
and this is real-time things
I'm hopping over 60 million entries in a
couple of seconds and to get my insight
and what what comes out of it is what
merge the results back to the task legs
that we had and then you get the basic
ideas that from the previous of the runs
was just 40 million files and not even
500 terabytes of data and there's
there's already something very
interesting here that you say we have
437 terabytes of data data all in all
and only 372 are organized in projects
so there's a vast amount of data around
which is still dark data which there's
no one aware of and which should be
restructured is that the idea I don't
believe so
the better idea is to make it available
by these sorts of systems but that's not
really it
lately we have time series data within
our data files that we use that's the
usual suspect if ye fear if you look at
the pipe that the pigs traveling through
the pipeline
it's obviously times they're related
it's irregular it's hard to get it done
but it's not organizing these files in
sort of this file system or data file
so what makes they see is to install it
or did you steal anything
it's MongoDB currently but it's a matter
of as we started prototyping it using
MongoDB it's something that we could
change learning time as we have lay on
top of it which is the REST API and
that's the final thing that's the API
the users do see what's possible for the
next they've got just not bottlenecks
they are obviously you know we have the
bottlenecks when when people were
searching for files and they didn't have
any chance so they're using they're
sitting in front of their Windows
desktop using the finder functionality
to find science on a 1.5 petabytes
filesystem that's not a good idea and
never ever completes you get the
impression you need to reboot your
computer of something so that was the
idea to have a clever table of contents
behind which is designed by the user
expectation and that's the idea when we
become strong entry to analyzing this
but these are sort of the questions that
people have like the IT departments how
many files are there how old are there
can you help us and sorting these things
arms and that's bi the idea behind it so
the bottleneck is no longer there's that
scan complete in an hour it is done
every night no one really takes care of
it
the next morning there is the new table
of contents available you can work on it
if you're running it just every night
the reason why you need to have it
making one our ministry as well is that
yes it could be the basic idea was to
not have it at night but to scale it
even more to be able to do it online at
some point maybe in a couple of minutes
and you can do it it's just a matter of
how many workers there are available and
using the desk secure shell protocol
spin off as many workers as you like
beginner you need a dynamically the
networking call that is the pieces that
are know as soon as you have say clones
of your computers all behaving single
term loosely the same and you have the
Anaconda installation at the very same
spot and have your secure shell set up
to not requiring passwords now you can
simply use a secure shell and turns off
your cluster in a couple of seconds and
then do your work
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]